irel um my office has a my company has
an office there I went over there work
days
okay folks we ready to
start are you ready to start okay
flag oh I don't want anybody saluting me
representative har yes uh please join me
with a pledge to our flag I pledge
allegiance to the flag of the United
States of America to the Republic for
which it stands one nation under God
Justice thank you thank you all for
being here and our uh work session on
retain bills uh got have to bear with me
I didn't take the retraining class to be
able to do this so I've got to start
over when you're when you get my age you
kind of used up most of the uh most of
your gray matter so I've got to do re
reuse a
few uh so let's why don't we start on
uh well wait a minute before I sorry
little bit of uh what how a work session
differs from a normal session a work
session is much more informal uh it's
it's
discussion uh I'll recognize uh I'll try
to recognize as many people I will qu
questions don't have to come through the
chair uh I I'm a lot
more
uh Lucy lot more informal
yeah you even didn't even wear a tie so
uh with that why don't we uh start with
the just start with the first one the
easiest one uh House Bill 186 and uh
Veil good morning um and thank you uh Mr
chair I spoke with the sponsor of the
bill yesterday at length and um so
in House Bill
186 this bill was filed um The graft and
taxpayers were paying 25% of their
County budget um secondary to a
relationship with the sewer company that
has been really difficult um we we heard
the bill we heard there were many flaws
with the bill and people brought out
some that are substantial that
would help us to realize that this bill
needs a lot of work no one has um
stepped up to do that work and get those
amendment in and uh the sponsors weren't
able to get that done and would like the
opportunity to bring this back having
considered all of the feedback and the
responses and Impressions that they got
chair so is uh What uh what is he
looking to uh he wants to be able to
come back so he wants us to itl it yes
that's what we could do and if if
um when we do the executive session um
that's the plan we will itl the bill and
they will be able to re re examine the
situation and see what can come further
for a better Bill
okay by the way there is uh we this is a
this is a work session we are not going
to exec anything we're just just going
to be find out where we stand and uh if
there what is we feel as a uh as a
committee needs uh we we need additional
information to make a final judgment so
there will be no exing today uh
so that is there anybody who has any
questions or uh any uh any thoughts on
how we might proceed do you have do you
so I think I'll just look for a
consensus uh that when we come
back uh and I'm looking at maybe the 1
of November or an executive session on
these on the bills that we have to uh
that there's no additional work on on
necessary on this bill and we all are
ready to uh make a a decision
and uh just I'll just look for a
consensus that will be look will we be
thinking about an
itl generally
and I won't bother taking a vote on it I
just uh let the record show that uh this
the uh these all seem to be in a
consensus and there's no additional
information needed uh why don't we move
on to uh House Bill
194 uh relative to requiring the
director of the division of archives and
Records management to compile and
maintain a list of
public
monuments the uh I
recall uh
this when we last had this bill
uh uh we we were split the committee was
split down the middle on uh uh on uh on
passing
or we were we're 10 to 10 on the bill
for on to to approve it to pass it uh
with that we decided to retain it
and because most of the concern seem to
be around the scope of the build and uh
that's really where where we uh want to
start
or I mean I I'll I'll I'll kind of as
one of the people who voted
uh not not to
approve uh my concern was
that I couldn't I didn't understand the
scope how much
information we were we would have to the
this bill talks about and we have to be
processed uh
there there are little there's inform
there's we just don't know uh who where
the where the money would come from I
can't uh don't know what the uh actual
work product would would really be
couldn't get uh a handle around that I
think that's where that's where I stand
I don't know if anybody else wish to
speak about it
representative thank you Mr chair um I I
maybe we could hear from the agency
representative because it it looks like
um new hampshire. goov already has a
website the list of markers I'm looking
at right now and so I I don't see
why was there a problem that this bill
is seeking to um remedy uh I don't think
I we ever had that clear so um we could
hear about that that would be good thank
you okay yeah it's good just just get
get any your thoughts out on the on the
table and then we can ask input from the
uh
from those that would would testify just
to get your you know why you voted the
way you did last last time repr
Simpson thank you um I was supporting
this bill because I heard the testimony
that it was really helpful for high
school students who are studying um
State history um and or competing in um
uh those quiz balls and things that they
do and just for them to get more um to
have a central place where they can go
for um more information State specific
information and then have that
to um either know more about their state
but also then they could do do um their
own trips or you know go to those places
throughout the state so it made sense to
me that it'd be something we should do
and I and I feel like we'd heard from
the administrator who would take this on
that um he would be able to uh do this
work without too much trouble so it
seemed to me like it um it would help
our help our young people and wouldn't
be a ton of extra work I I think because
they have a website already and it would
be adding to it and it's actually not as
complicated as it sounds or as timec
consuming maybe um so I would love to
hear if that is still the case from it
looks like the sponsor has worked on
some new language to see how that new
language came about I'd love to hear
that thanks repres representative
Brun just to give some history on this
bill I remember seeing it um come before
us says the LSR it was from freshman rep
uh representative gero jamana from Keen
uh representative Jana is a history
professor at Keen state college so I
look at this as something that if he
thinks it's important it is um but the
flaw with the bill as it was originally
submitted is that it delegated this um
responsibility to the department uh the
division of archives and Records
management and I at that time I called
representative jamao and Jama and I said
I think this is more appropriate to go
with the division of historical and
cultural resources which we already have
in place and I talked to Ben Wilson this
is back probably a year ago and he said
oh yeah this is something we could
easily do we interact with town and City
historical societies anyway we could
compile this information and once every
10 years just circle back with them and
make sure if there's any new markers or
new monuments we could and compile them
um and after that conversation he said
that there would be no fiscal note that
we already have this um because when it
came with the fiscal note initially it
was because it was going to a department
that didn't already have this
responsibility so it's going to the
appropriate division at no extra costs
every 10 years they have to compile this
list to make it publicly available um
there are many things the state can miss
from their website because it may be
held by a local local Historical Society
I know that in miramac we have really
fostered um our historical society and I
don't think it would really come to
their mind to submit that to division of
historical resources so I think having a
system in here where every 10 years that
can be reviewed would be a positive for
our state and not just for our students
but I think all members of the public
would appreciate knowing that historical
richness of our state and this would be
a One-Stop shop to get those kinds that
kind of information so I I support the
bill as
amended where it goes into the
appropriate
Department any other anoun on
representative
gold I think that's a good point that uh
you know if there's no cost that was my
concern seemed like a big cost for this
but with another division taking care of
it that sounds good and I was thinking
maybe the kids wouldn't be going to
these volums but you know how people go
to um covered bridges and things like
that maybe they could add going to The
Monuments but if there's no cost and
it's in the division that can do it for
free I don't see why can be done I think
we have to discuss costs that's was one
of the one of the issues when we uh uh
when we first saw this bill okay so that
I think is going to to be part of our
discussion
because okay let is repres
representative thank you Mr chairman so
one of my concerns is this physical
markers would it
include Town
boundaries the reason I ask is that
towns are required to do
perambulations uh every seven years uh
where they're supposed to go around and
verified their property lines uh which
are usually mocked by a strange set of
boundaries for example in Farmington we
have a point where there's a pile of
rocks with initials on it where Five
Towns come together only place in the
state that happens a few yards in one of
the markers is a big boulder and this is
how it's defined in the in the records
uh from 18 something uh big boulder four
rocks on top lift the rocks and there's
a
date this is how it's described that's
what you're looking for and I can tell
you as of a couple of years ago that's
there would that be something that would
be included in physical markers and have
the towns actually done the uh the every
sevene check of their boundaries I'm not
sure about that see that is not of
itself
see
yeah maybe I shouldn't respond to that
but that's a
question that is a question of the bill
is the spe specificity around what
you're actually going to be including in
the in the data and how
many how many points of data are we
talking 10 100 there's 22 was it
221 towns 10 counties 13 cities and 25
unincorporated areas in the state of New
Hampshire if all if every one of them
puts in 10 the 10 10 monuments and I
know there's just 10 monuments within
within within 300 feet of this of this
room uh what there could be the heck of
a lot of data and I think we have to
Veil thank you Mr chair um I just think
this bill is a really powerful way to
keep history alive in New Hampshire and
also that it's um important because it
brings the study of history and the
institutional knowledge of history in
New Hampshire in the state which we know
is very valuable and we always try to
preserve um outside the classroom where
everyone has access and I I really
support this kind of database what I
know about software is that once you get
the program running it really doesn't
matter how much data that you are
putting into it except for the the fact
that you may have technological
limitations so I have full faith that
this can be done um and it can be done
in
expensively if it's if there's any
expense thank you anyone who has spoken
time thank
you oh I'm sorry I didn't
see Mr chair I just have a concerns
about the word all it says all monuments
all I mean who who holds people
accountable for every single Monument I
mean is I think it's a great idea I
think it's a great um asset it will be a
great asset to us but when we start with
all I'm not sure how that's regulated or
how that works it's an overwhelming word
to me that's very good
point
representative uh is someone else no oh
representative har for first for our
first time thank you Mr chair um I also
have concerns about the extent and the
definitions of what will be um
accumulated by the division of
historical resources and I certainly
would like to see a letter or something
from them confirming there's no
additional cost because I find that a
little hard to believe that there's not
some cost to it um so the fiscal note
I'd like to hear from the historical
resources maybe they can tweak what
they're already doing
and maybe limit um somewhat or Define
what they would want to categorize thank
you
time har bull for a second for a second
time thank you for your Indulgence um I
I agree with my colleague down there
about some of the language and and I'm
you know just to just to reiterate I'm
perfectly I think this a great
program and I think the wayf finding and
the markers and having a list of the
markers is definitely worthwhile as I
said there is already somebody is
already doing it I'd like to so if you
go on the website it says um there's the
list of the markers and it says that uh
that somebody is is there's a highway
marker program and it's administered by
uh Amy Dixon um in coordination with the
New Hampshire
do it's called the historic Highway
marker program it says it's jointly
managed by the New Hampshire division of
historical resources and New Hampshire
Department of
Transportation am I to I just have a
question am I to understand that they no
longer want to administer this it what's
going on with the transfer because
clearly it's already being administered
and managed managed formally and we
haven't heard from those people so I
think it would be worthwhile to kind of
reach out and see what's going on as far
you reprentative Simpson for a second
time thank you um so it's my
understanding that that list is only
Highway markers though and doesn't
include monuments so I'm not sure um if
there's a list of monuments
um already on that site but my my
feeling is
administratively that it would be a way
to have all the monuments in the same
way that this that the highway markers
are um but my uh I would like to ask the
sponsor if we can talk to him in a
minute I I think that's a great question
to ask him um but the other thing I
wanted to say is that I don't get the
feeling that this bill is in any way
meant to be be punitive there are no um
there are no sort of consequences
written into the bill if somebody were
to miss a monument in terms of all
monuments I think a I think that um it's
not necessarily if if your Historical
Society were to forget to add a monument
in a in a conversation with the cultural
resource's office I don't think that
somebody would be punished for that I
think it's a a good faith attempt to
make sure that every 10 years we would
update the list to show to reflect any
new monuments um I'm just sort of
imagining how that works administrative
I I didn't take that to be I didn't take
that to be punitive I just talk took it
as what you know what's what does this
what does this Encompass there I mean we
call gravestones
monuments uh and I don't know if that uh
does this
cover cemeteries uh things like things
like that there's all there's so much
you could put into something like this
especially if the the we because his
history by itself is Broad you'd like to
be able to get all information and what
information are you going to put into
this uh that's yeah representative ghoul
for a second you could even add the
railroad markers along the rail
as you say we don't know what this
encompasses there are markers along the
so representative Darby for the first
start thank thank you Mr chair just I
mean just reading the amendment um in
particular because I think that's that's
really where the clarity is it does say
maintained by state and local
authorities so it's it's not it's not as
broad as we're we're talking about here
it's the it's um the set that um you
know municipalities and the state is
already responsible for and so they can
reach right out to these municipalities
it's not wandering around the fields and
things like
that response to that I just heard
historical societies well they're not
part of the towns or the well I'm
telling say what the amendment says the
amendment says um exactly so you're not
going to do put historical
societies I mean I would put his IAL
sociey in there myself we're doing I
know it's that that's kind of the that's
kind thing really why we're here is the
that's fine but I just I I just was
thinking that we could scope it to
what's in this amendment yeah okay we
could do that but we we'll again
we'll what be because uh we're well
let's see how far we get today but I I
think uh uh we probably might want to
consider
uh I've been been considering it and I I
can do it establish a uh a subcommittee
to spend additional time and try to try
to rework the bill if it's
possible uh anyone else from the on the
committee
with for the first time was that um it
seems to me that it's not a big ask of a
division of historical
resources to do an inventory every 10
years um mean what else does the
division do
except to to do this kind of work and I
think the big component is to include um
the Outreach to Educators in the state
every 10 years to let them know what's
out
there so I don't see why it seems that
division representative rung for the
thank you representative L Montaine
echoed what I was going to say we have a
division of historical resources what
are they doing if they're not compiling
a list of our historical resources but
we're going around and around and I know
that the director wasn't able to be here
today but I know he's going to be
available next week is this something
that we can put on agenda for next week
because it seems like all of our
questions are ones that he can be the he
can answer have someone from
the you are here for the for to talk
about
huh oh okay okay okay so you're not okay
I I
misunderstood
yes but uh we we could uh well again
talk about a uh putting a subcommittee
together to be able to really Bor borrow
down into this
and representative Darby and then I'm
there's no one else after representative
Darby I would like to definitely get the
representative jna into the into the
conversation I i' just like to point out
that under the Department of Natural and
cultural resources there is a bureau of
historic sites and there is a chief
supervisor of the bureau um for these so
um in line with uh what representative
La montin was saying you know we could
speak to that uh Chief supervisor we
could understand the um the definition
of uh how he would interpret how they
I'm sorry how they would interpret uh
these monuments being maintained by
state and local authorities and the
impact of uh of accumulating these once
every 10 years and that's uh EST
a10d I'm seeing no one else with a
specific statement or question why don't
you come up take a take a
seat
uh I know is there anyone else who is
actually going to be interested in this
bill who would like to be able to get
representative
it
if it doesn't operate we can we have a
so said should I ask him to sit in uh
take a
yeah but
pardon you can okay yeah why just I know
I know representative McHugh is not here
and so go right ahead yeah
representative gerana you're
can uh well this is more conversational
I just want to open this adversarial I
hope
and just say say what you have to say
with round what you heard thank you very
much I'd like to thank the chair and all
of you uh today uh I want to thank
summarizing
okay thank you very much uh I want to
thank representative rung for
summarizing the history of how this bill
came to be I was a brand new legislator
when I introduced it uh and not knowing
which departments were appropriate I'm a
historian so to me I think archives
right and so that's kind of where my
mind went but fortunately with some help
from representative rung uh and some
others kind of made the right
connections and and ended up speaking
with Ben Wilson about uh you this
fitting appropriately in in what the
Department of uh historical and cultural
resources does I also want to uh thank
representative veale for for her
comments in particular about the idea of
of keeping history alive that's
obviously something I care a great deal
about I think probably all of us do uh
you know monuments are very often in our
towns things we pass by every day
without really reflecting on them right
and one of my interests as a historian
is you know how we can make history
something which we engage with regularly
and and and think about especially in a
a state with uh such a long and great
history as as New
Hampshire uh I also have have learned in
my first term as a rep and I I think I
understand why right we don't like to
have days for particular people or
particular events right you know those
kind of have the governor make a
proclamation and um uh and I understand
that and and you know some folks from my
part of the state for example we wanted
to have a granny D Day right that was
one of the bills that we voted on I
understand the the reasons for not
wanting to to have all of these days but
one of the responses that we often hear
which I think is a valid one is well
look that should be kind of done at the
local level right so if you want to
celebrate granny D it would be a lot
more meaningful to have a celebration in
chesher County she was from
Peterboro or to have a marker of some
kind in chesher County right that that
would actually be a lot more meaningful
than a Proclamation signed by the
governor I completely agree with that so
one of the things that this bill would
do would be
through specifically through schools I'm
thinking about middle school high school
but I also think through historical
societies is hopefully kind of generate
conversations I would absolutely love to
have a group of middle school or high
school students have history projects
for their County or their their Town
based on uh the the markers that are out
there and to say well who could we add a
marker to right so somebody like granny
d and if you had students who then went
to town hall or came here and made an
argument about why a certain person is
worthy of having a monument or a marker
uh in their town so that that was part
of my thinking about how this could fit
in particular we're also talking a lot
about Civics education right a new
Civics textbook that we're helping to
fund to me it goes hand inand teaching
local history with our students with our
objective in terms of a a more robust
Civics education
I do think that a lot of the questions
that you've asked regarding the work of
the department absolutely Ben Wilson uh
director Wilson is the best person to be
able to answer those questions I can
tell you that I drafted the wording that
is in the amendment with director Wilson
right so uh all of the for example as as
representative Darby pointed out
specifically focusing on that word
maintain by local or state authorities
right so the mile markers that's already
there right because it's maintained by
the state the state already has that but
a locality will have a list of
maintained markers um and in terms of
whether you're talking about working
with the the the local government or
historical societies again at the
direction of of the director that was
left vague because it was not to kind of
prescribe to them the manner in which
they would work with Folks at the local
level in order to get that information
right so it it was intentionally not to
name specific groups that they would
work with as I said at the director's
request because again they have those
relationships already uh and this allows
them more flexibility in terms of of
information so those are my uh
initial uh thoughts in response to some
of the thoughtful questions you all have
asked
uh in terms of again the expense
obviously the director is the person to
answer that question when I spoke with
him about this again he said he used the
the mile Highway mile marker as a good
example he said look this is what we
want to do we are actually actively
trying to uh reflect on our state's
history and our cultural heritage and
have that represented uh and he s sees
this and again he can speak to but then
maybe if he speaks to a subcommittee he
sees this as going hand inand with what
they are doing right so that that mile
marker program is part of a proactive
program by the department to do exactly
what I hoping that this bill will
accomplish and so he sees it working
with the work the the department is
history
REO he rebooted okay good all right uh
just couple of things that that jumped
this we have a whole lot of now there do
you talk about mile markers are you
referring to the signs that say uh this
is the birth that that we they put up
this that actually
uh repres director
Wilson's uh area uh his uh his
department is is responsible for the
business of the the signs that uh here
on this this is the birthplace of so and
so it was it was recently in in the in
the news concerning the the Communist
who
was put the her uh
that uh that sign was was later taken
down I think uh but it's that kind of
thing these are all over the state is
that what what he mean by markers or is
that me mile marker is yes I apologize I
should not have used the word mile
markers they are historical markers
along their Highway markers but correct
I misspoke when I said mile markers okay
I mean there's one right in front of the
front of the the uh the several yeah the
uh the libraries are different markers I
prefer
historical and so you're looking for
stuff like that how
about uh
monuments Civil War
monuments uh Hall of flags has uh as are
all kinds of markers we
have markers of of plaques of throughout
throughout the state of the those who
lost their lives in the various wars
Civil War the especially the especially
World War I and World War II you have
you have those markers are all those
considered
be uh it's that's where the scope comes
in I I was doing some looking
online and uh on cannons you realize how
many cannons there are in the state of
New Hampshire I know the in nasua they
they've got three around the uh the the
monument the the Civil War Monument that
big tall thing at the top of Library
Hill yeah top of Library Hill there's
three there's not only there's three
there there's also from World War I
there's a German Howitzer later on in
the park so I of from World War I all of
those I would assume are monuments you'd
be surprised there are
tanks that are monuments that in front
of the V various vfw's are they going to
be
part yeah if I may first of all I would
say that if they are maintained by local
authorities first of all uh there was
somebody in that town who already has a
list because they are being maintained
so it's a matter of a list which is
being sent from from local authority to
the Department of historical and
cultural resources and then put on a
website but I would also say uh Mr chair
that the examples that you just gave are
a great example everybody should know
everybody in the state should know what
those monuments are that they're there
right I mean how many monuments do we
know in our own towns because we live
there and we don't know the richness of
the state's history because we don't
know much of anything about monuments in
other parts of the state that are part
of our our history so I would argue that
the examples you just gave are actually
an argument in favor of this bill
because everyone should know they're
there I I don't I don't disagree I
mean I I love history I I got got a
website here that's artill artillery and
armor in the USA New Hampshire so it's
got and if if you want to know which if
you tell me your town I'll tell you
which guns are in
it
mortars so that's I mean Bristol in the
Amherst and all so there and there there
is history all over and I don't but it's
it's just
the the scope of what we're talking
about is what I'm concerned with because
I don't have my hands around it and we
talk about dealing with the
locals it it's one thing if we get into
the bill
that the there is such a thing as 91a if
we ask for it we got to pay for
it so they have to be a we have to get
worked into the bill
that it's the information that that you
receive you you it's they're giving it
to to uh to the state they're not giving
it to us at the demand of the
state because once you ask for if you
say you got to we need this at this data
they'll say okay it's going to cost us
this amount of money to be able to go
and check stuff out
uh that's that's one of the issues the
other issue I think uh is getting data
into the this say about we do this once
every 10 years do you just accumulate
the
stuff new any new stuff or do you just
send out a call and it's say okay one
year get it all in and if you don't get
it
in well see it 10 years from now well
could could I speak to that well I
imagine and again the director would be
the the best person to ask about that
but exactly so what I imagine would
happen is right every nine years right
or so every 10 years right the uh the
department would send out this request
to the local authorities with whom they
have relationships and basically then
it's updating the list right I mean
there's at that point there the amount
of work that would be done to update a
list after its initial creation would be
minimal because a locality would only be
reporting if any new monuments had been
uh placed uh during that period of 10
years so the maintenance of the list
would be really really minimal
and finally they let it go ask others to
to ask their
questions I and if if uh Mr Mr Wilson
were here it' be aimed at him but you're
here so uh
it's and I think it was
uh why don't I
just what
what would the what would the the quote
List look like would it be a database
where you have and how much information
will be put into this
list uh it it it it's it's one thing if
you're making a Excel spreadsheet and
that's it and you got couple you know
one sentence and and this is what it is
and forget about it or do you have some
kind of database which
you look I do do you envision the type
of where somebody could click on well I
want to see what this looks like and
boom it takes you to a to another file
that file comes up and says this is what
this this this is that's that's a really
a research tool other than that um it's
more the list is just a
list so but anyway that's my uh
representative
Kelly thank you Mr chair um yeah I think
I i' point to DN uh the division of
flest and lands keeps a list of rare
plant species they have to mandate
they're mandated to to track it every
five years that that list I mean that's
just an Excel spreadsheet i' assume
something like that would be appropriate
um and it is just a Excel spreadsheet
but you can look up your town and watch
for airplants are there and all that
information if yeah if I may also yeah
exact exactly I mean for for the
purposes of this bill uh it it is just
keeping that kind of list uh for the
state and and you know if if the
department had the resources and the
time to be able to make it a research
tool as as you were just describing I
think that would be great but I also
think it's unlikely uh so in this case
it is the purpose of the list is to make
all of that information publicly
available again I I return to the the
the good examples uh that that you gave
a few minutes ago right so that having I
I would say a list is not just a list a
list indicates to people that something
is there that they may not have known
was there uh and that I think can have
tremendous value for you know teachers
and schools particularly again around
Civics and New Hampshire history so yes
I I Envision it as being simply a a list
comparable to what is currently uh
online as representative Harvey bolia
pointed out with regard to the uh
Highway way markers um that is
accessible in a similar kind of format
but uh that's the best I can can answer
that question and certainly uh the
depth would you consider um including
cemeteries
um it seems there are a lot of uh old
cemeteries that may have started out as
private or family cemeteries that are
abandoned but eventually they can be
taken over by the city or town um and
would that be
included yeah thank you for that
question I know cemeteries came up
earlier um and we actually we have some
of our students in Keen State too who do
research um on local history using
cemeteries in in the Reg
and again uh we already have processes
right whereby cemeteries can be um uh
searching for the right word for this
but can be acknowledged to have
historical significance right and we
have probably all of us in our towns
historic cemeteries uh and they have uh
they're recognized by towns and and so
bottom line is you know uh not all
cemeteries presumably would fall into
this category but there are categories
that we all there are cemeteries that we
all have in our communities that are
acknowledged as of historic significance
so again I also want to emphasize that
uh and it was a point that was made by
representative Simpson uh you know that
this obviously is not punitive but where
I want to go with that is to say the the
point is to get the best information we
possibly can have right so uh this
question about and I hear that uh there
was a concern about the question of all
monuments I'm not sure what word you
would substitute in in a bill right
you'd say some most uh but the point is
to do the best that we can do right in
terms of providing as comprehensive a
list as possible right so I don't
imagine that this is going to cover
absolutely everything that everybody
would regard as being of historical
significance and again to representative
Derby's Point that's why the the the
specific reference to maintained by
local or state authorities because that
narrows the range
um speaking also to the Chairman's
concerns about the scope that narrows
the scope of what we're talking about
right because without that I think we
are talking about well what is a
historical monument uh and we can get
into a gray area about that so
cemeteries I think uh that are
acknowledged by towns as being of
historic significance would absolutely
fall into that and and towns would have
now
my question's been answered thank
you I just want to say thank you very
much for clearing up some information
for
me okay when you talk about the
cemeteries um that's that's what when
the chair speaks about the scope um the
cemetery for Veterans Day this year we
went out and did the flags like we
always do
um the historical society was there and
the veterans were there and my wife was
there and she said why aren't you
putting flags on the the graves that
have G on them and they said well what's
g mean they Historical Society didn't
know veterans didn't know it's the Grand
Army of the Republic they were the
original army so are those historical
monuments are those all going to have to
be marked that's where I where I have
the problem with the scope um my wife
also sits on the historical society and
the historical Commission of
town they have a very hard time filling
those positions they're voluntary so it
should be more voluntary for the town to
do these um historical commissions are
mandated by LSR but commissions are not
so when you deal with this their their
lists may be good they they not be
comprehensive so there cannot be any
punitive if something misses that's the
big thing so you may not be get it so it
almost should be vol to the towns to be
all yeah and if I may I appreciate that
and I did not know that so thank you um
what I would say however is those are
not I am assuming publicly maintained
right so again that reference to public
maintenance limits the scope of of what
we're talking about actually that
cemetery is public mainten well then
then it would be if it's publicly well
the cemetery right being publicly
maintained so then it is but it's not
publicly maintained as probably as a
historic site but again it depends on uh
the town would be the one to report that
right and so it would go on the list if
the the town reports it on the voluntary
side of things again because there is
nothing punitive
right in essence that's what we're
talking about right because the the
department is not going to expend a
great deal of Labor tracking down people
who don't report right and there's no
mechanism to enforce that on purpose so
I mean effectively it is voluntary but I
think we we all know even with limited
resources I I was on the board of our
Historical Society for a few
years I I imagine that most would be
really eager you know the Historical
Society folks are generally really
really eager to get this uh kind of
information out there but to your point
which I think is an excellent one
effectively we're talking about
something that's voluntary because
there's no enforcement mechanism and nor
be
did it again uh so I'd like toh set up a
uh
subcommittee
of I'll ask for volunteers but it's got
to be uh uh at at least four people you
got to have for every it's got to be
bipartisan it's got to be equally
equally
split
uh do I have any volunteers right
now
representative
Ryan
R
Ryan all right do I have any
Republicans because it's got to be
you're going to be on it right uh I
will I guess I
will I guess I'll have to be hon it all
right
me anyone else any other
Republican
okay really
no I need I need you and you yeah
because I need three so it makes it up
now yeah right rung Ryan Vale Zulo
bolia by the way anybody can come we're
only talking about these are the voting
members anybody can come anybody get can
get get say they whatever they they
please they can participate as a rep in
the only thing that can it comes to a
final vote if there even is a final vote
especially we I think we're talking
about if any anything trying to reach a
consensus if possible around a it's it's
the vote it's the vote that uh the
voting members will put the consensus
together
and uh we'll help hopefully write
a a an amendment that might if if it's
possible we can agree with to be able
to to to get the job
there that
it Mr chair would it be okay to schedule
that subcommittee um maybe after before
the one we have already scheduled on the
18th uh I know that date was conveni
vent for Mr
Wilson uh what the uh 18th
yeah uh that might not be a bad
idea uh but
remember
uh I'm just looking
uh on that I've already uh we'll have to
we'll have we'll have to be at a
different time
because you are
you would be on this you would be on
both committees right now uh both
subcomittees I haven't I haven't put
anybody on yet but you already know I've
already asked you about that that's
right but we wouldn't schedule them to
meet all at the same time no no it's but
just just realize that
maybe uh I think that that one is
scheduled for 10
o'clock
check I think that's yes 398 39 398 is
at 10
o'
so
uh we'll and I'll be I'll be talking
398 so at the at the end of our end of
our
meeting on this are we done we got it so
um what about 1:00 the same day yeah
that's I me if he happens to be
o'clock okay
one
18th night okay very good I'd like to
thank the chair and thank all of you for
conversation this
morning hopefully we're not as long on
the the next
two all
along hope we're not we spent almost an
hour on that one uh 430 434 relative to
flying drones and state
parks
uh repres yeah why don't we I don't is
that is that operable
okay where did uh
we we kind of vot V well we just just
put this into
uh four no House Bill
I think we the uh the there's amendment
that I guess is coming
forward uh could uh you wish to speak to
uh for the record representative Lisa
post from lineboro uh thank you for um
letting me speak this morning uh this is
um an amendment to HB
434 um we removed some
language and what we did that made a
significant difference is um line 16 and
17 which allows the commissioner to
adopt rules under 541a to implement the
restrictions in paragraph 1 any other
limitations on drone use and state parks
and criteria to wave any of these
restrictions so this will will allow the
parks to set the boundaries um instead
of us you know asking for something
specifically um and I think that would
make it easier to work with the um the
parks department to get it done with
that language um and we already have
restrictions on there so um we're
willing to take some of those
restrictions that and work with them to
get this done
to pass
it in our state parks is there someone
from the uh parks department
all have they been uh have they been
provided a copy of this
uh this amendment this proposed
amendment so the the parks no not not at
this time we we just got this done so um
kind of late late uh to the game on it
but we were just trying to come up with
some um uh Solutions um because we were
kind of at a standstill with the parks
department um the last time we spoke
with them so uh this is to you know try
to get this through um with the
cooperation of the parks department um I
in looking up um some other
uh states that have done this um
California if you look at California
they do it in the Parks and uh at the
beaches and um they have many um many
areas that they can go to and they have
restrictions on them in some things and
there is also local control in towns um
so they have the ability to do that so
so some of the rules that you know we
could put on this working with the parks
department um would provide um
assurances that people aren't um you
know surveilling other people and things
like that and um California has um some
really good restrictions that we could
use as a basis for um you know putting
in there any questions uh representative
ghoul I think I was still during the
original hearing but my question is some
state parks are quite large like be
Brook for example or uh pck away and you
could be hiking way out away from your
parking lot and a drone goes by how
would you know who's doing that if they
bother you
somehow
so um I think
what whoops um thank you uh so what
we're trying to do is establish a place
to launch and a a place to come back so
a person um would have to um with with
restrictions have to be in a certain
area right and um as we had it before
where it was on the trail system now
this is in the Parks and we're hoping
what we can do with this bill is to
designate certain areas and E there may
even be we could do certain times of the
year I mean I think there's a lot to
look at and unpack with this um
regarding rules around it to make it
safe
for people who are on the Trails um or
not on the trails excuse me in the state
parks hiking and things like that so I
think we could work together with the
department and and you know try to make
the best
possible um and start allowing you know
drones to be in certain areas and maybe
we can build on it maybe we can start
small pick certain Parks
think representative Ron thank you Mr
chair um thank you representative post
for the amendment but um I I'm looking
back at my notes from the public hearing
and um I I still see these issues
haven't been resolved and they were
brought up by U Miss uh Trisha Lambert
she's with the Bureau of Aeronautics at
do and she had said that drones are not
defined in RSA so I don't see a
definition here the and that the
Aerospace is regulated by the FAA that
the state can't do that there is no
requirement for
insurance RSA 644 already covers privacy
and that charging for flight is a per
rview of the FAA can only charge for
takeoff and Landing but emergency
landing should be allowed so I wish I
took a little more detailed notes but I
don't see how the the B the big thing
that I see with this is that um that air
space is regulated by FAA so how do we
get around that like so actually um
that's already in in law so we don't
have to worry about that because once it
it takes off it's in that airspace and
it can be
there okay so the FAA allows that they
do oh okay and then um it's it's just
the takeoff and the landing that's the
issue okay and and do you know is are
are drones um defined in statutes
somewhere other than this
chapter well I do know I I don't know
for the um for our state and and perhaps
uh Drew Melman who this is um a
constituent bill would he be able to
come and address
that when now her question oh
yeah this is that this is an an
open this type of hearing uh work
session anyone is can speak yeah I'm not
aware of where it's def find in statute
but I know there was uh some work that
was done on that within the past couple
years I don't know if it actually got
passed um as far
as I'm sorry what was the other part of
the question uh it was really about the
definition I know we've worked on
several watercraft bills over the years
and it is important to Define because
they may come out with a drone next year
that's monstrous and maybe but if if we
don't Define like the size and the um
mechanics of the
Drone anything could then be defined by
a as and and be called a drone and be
put in so I think it is good having a
definition of what we are regulating
here what we are allowing whatever that
definition would be would mimic
something that's already in place in the
fars Federal Aviation regulations and
they do have a definition of of what
that would be um so if we do have a
definition adopted we would probably
mimic what's already in place for
federal law and then you also had a
point about um this bill having maybe
overlap with federal laws and Trisha
Lambert's concerned with that in this
amend we actually took out um some
mention of the flight aspect and this
bill right now as it stands only deals
with takeoff and landing and that's
something really only under our our
prview that's the only thing we can
regulate okay that sounds good I I would
like to um try and get a definition in
you know or have this this um Bill
reference a definition in New Hampshire
statutes so it doesn't leave it
open-ended so not anybody can Define it
statute and I just want to mention um
doing some lookup while I was in the
back there um there are new drone laws
in um the United States now and looking
through these I can send them all to to
you so it's it's actually kind of
informative but it's also inclusive of
drone use okay thank you yeah and they
you representative
Derby thank you Mr chair just um just to
follow up on representative Rong um she
did specifically say to use the
definitions in RSA 422 that's what she's
recommended not drone so that's what um
if to to get Mr Lambert's uh you know to
align with what Miss Lambert was
suggesting I would look at the
definitions in RSA 422 and I do think
that there are still a couple of wording
challenges here in terms of you know for
example in um where's the use here yeah
so line 17 it says limitations on drone
use in state parks you know I think you
really want to limit that to take off in
Landings explicitly like you like you're
suggesting um and the
um yeah and I and I there's one other
small tweak which is that the
um the existing um I on page two at line
one it said the commissioner shall adopt
rules only for the uh assessment and
payment of fees and that sort of
contradicts the new Clause that you put
in about adopting rules so I think
there and she also is excuse me that is
actually for the commercial use we're
only looking at Hobby use um I'm I'm
amendment oh if you're talking about RSA
422 so this is um RSA 541a only for the
assessment and payment of fees for
operators of small unmanned aircraft for
commercial
purposes okay but um it the the problem
I had is it says shall adopt rules only
so that seemed to contradict the um
Clause to which said shall be able to
adopt rules to implement the
restrictions yeah I'll check on that
like I think if you just get rid of only
there that'd be fine
okay thank
you and and she did just um as a
reminder the insurance thing also came
up from Miss Lambert so I think there's
a a piece there that needs to be
reconciled
thanks
the insurance requirement is not
something I'm aware of in other states
requirement representative done that's
actually one of my questions is who is
responsible is the state responsible if
somebody comes on the property and one
of these drones hits somebody that's
hiking who has the
responsibility if someone's
injured um as far as violations of
airspace rules that would have to go to
the FAA so there's a whole um reporting
procedure that state parks would have to
go through and local police are doing
this already um they would have to
report incidences to the the FAA but if
there is property damage or damage to
the state parks on the grounds then then
there is some some overlap how much of a
burden is that going to put on the state
parks right now if they have to report
all these
incidents and I don't know if you could
put a a number on that but like you
already do have the ability to fly in
the airace above state parks that's
something that's currently permitted and
um this perhaps puts in processes in
place to help Streamlight that and um
have a better capability of dealing with
situations and also just
um to confirm that um you can you can
stand at the edge of a road on the
outside of the park right and you can
set you know launch and and land the
Drone there um so those things already
happen um this is to give people a safe
area to be in and be able to you know
use some of the beauty of you know our
our New Hampshire resources and and take
pictures and use them for many different
things but it's more as a hobby than
um the commercial use so that's the
distinction between the two um with
where the rules get set up for um
hobbyists as opposed to there's already
commercial um laws in place for that I
was just concerned about the liability
like if we if we say they're they're
allowed in this Zone and somebody gets
hurt in that zone with a drone is the
state
responsible question I believe that's
already in the bill like there is a
clause somewhere in here about um
assuming all liability for the
went I see that so does the state have a
vetting process for the insurance
because what if the person doesn't have
insurance I mean that's just not a
common requirement most people don't
carry insurance for this type of stuff I
mean it would um just we don't require
insurance for driving a car a vehicle um
and this is recreational use you you
could a you know children 17 year olds
my my nephew
flies this
uh these these uh unmanned aerial
aircraft so I I believe the technical
term that representative post is looking
for his recreational use um and I I
think it's uh worth looking at this bill
a little bit more closely and seeing if
we can get something that's uh um still
has a lot of restrictions when it's you
know as it's new and we'll look at
California and uh and see if we can
start small maybe
and and test it out yeah uh the state
would not be liable for any of this it's
just like it's just like anything else
um if you're driving a bike in the the
park or uh had any other sort of
accident on the state park there's
thank you Mr chair um I still have the
same concern concerns that I had when we
heard the bill
originally
um some of them have already been
covered drones not being defined as
drones I mean they're unmanned vehicles
and we were told that we need to use the
right
terminology but I'm wondering like we
have unmanned state Parks they're not
manned all year round who's handing out
waivers that say that the state's not
responsible if you hit somebody with
your drone um and I think yeah you're in
federal airspace right up until you
impact something or somebody so we're
asking you know we're asking the person
who's doing this to be able to do
everything that they can do for their
drone that would make it safe but we
don't have a way to um leverage that
kind of safety like we would with an
insurance policy and really clear
outlined um really clear outlined
um about um sorry I was sudden it went
out of my head um what we want to do is
we want to be able to be sure that our
state parks can handle this and that the
people can handle this and that all of
the unmanned vehicle operators
are liable and they're they they know we
make statute every day about Recreation
um recreational vehicles and we do want
to know what's going to happen when they
impact people and we really need to know
what's going to happen when something
goes wrong so I I think that sums up
what I'm saying in the last sentence
it's like so what happens when
something's goes wrong and there's just
so much about this that we are new to um
but I'm continuing to look at this and
to see some of these ideas that we could
try I do think that Statute in other
states is a good place to look I don't
know if we'll find a fit for this bill
in New Hampshire but there's no problem
else um Mr
chair is $25 a day for commercial use of
Business I'm asking I don't know my
thought is my thought is that is just a
lot of money if I'm a commercial
photographer or um whatever you know
$25 I think they're going to fly every
single day I think they I'm uh I've I've
actually uh got my uas at one point it's
expired now but um I think probably they
may fly for a week at a time and take
their photos during a season a certain
season or whatnot and maybe uh maybe it
is I'm not sure I can't answer that one
but just um about the Civil liability
again um it's the same as if you bring a
dog into a park that injures somebody we
don't require Insurance on your animals
that you bring in it's handled in small
claims court if there are problems but
that's also one of the reasons for the
permits H it's um educational and um and
also to to know who's in the park and in
filming but and then the third thing is
um and you get that um sorry I lost my
trying of thought with that one um you
get
your
educational point and then um you know
we don't uh require people can fly
through the park already I mean that's
once they're up in the air we don't
there's no way to require Insurance of
these people who are flying over the
park as well so it's I'm sure I know
people have flown in the Parks um but
just to clarify that part about the
Civil liability thanks maybe maybe
representative post can talk about our
um the uh the person who put forth the
$25 I don't think it's too prohibitive
and I think um the original intent and
at least one of the original versions of
the bill was that you could
retroactively pay that $25 like let's
say you go flying a day and then um you
might end up using the pictures
commercially you could go back and pay
the $25 to the state when you actually
end up using the photos for commercial
purpose
um there's one other thing that I lost
my
thought any did you get your question
answer representative Derby and
representative R definitely we've heard
a few times here that it's already
permitted to fly over Parks so I'm just
all this would allow us to launch and
take off within the parks and that could
potentially um help alleviate some of
the safety concerns like instead of
launching from a more dangerous place
and flying miles away over to the park
you could be in a safer place to launch
and land um it would also give greater
access to um more interesting places to
fly um and one other point that I'm
going to make is people are doing this
already like like they're not even
paying attention to any of those rules
if you go on YouTube right now you can
see amazing drone videos of Crawford
Notch and um Franconia Notch State Park
people are doing this already so I think
it's a lot smarter if we have some rules
in place to better regulate that and
better be equipped or to be better
situations and i' just like to add if if
we put permitting on here people have to
fill out a form and so all their
information will be on there so if
someone gets injured we'll know who has
been there I'm sure we would have time
in timeout that type of thing so it's
all about putting rules in place to make
it safer for both people who are in the
Parks and for the people who are landing
Landing representative R thank you um
one of the things um
that concerns me still though is a
letter we received from um Mr Brian
Wilson from he's the uh director of the
division of Parks and Recreation have
you seen a copy of
that um representative did you ever
getet I'll get copies made this is where
I still have a concern though he
mentions in his letter and he this was
submitted during his testimony at the um
public hearing but he said we are very
concerned with the impact that bill
would have on the recreational
experience of our visitors in state
parks campgrounds and trails including
those trails that cross private land
protecting the quality of that
experience is one of the purposes of our
administrative rules and he goes into
more detail I don't know if you if
you've seen this letter so yes that was
from the previous and I think that was
his previous testimony here as well um
we have had meetings with him about it
um I thought he was sending someone here
today but um anyway anyway uh with that
um the fact
that he was talking about trails and
things like this this eliminates the
trails this is just simply in the park
system for a launch and
land so that's the differentiation from
the last bill How It Was Written okay
thank
you
um we're talking about forms and
documentation what about all of our
unman Parks who takes care of that who
who's responsible for generating those
forms where do they
go I mean I hike all the time and I
never see that would be the parks
department so if you think about it when
you if you want to have a fire you know
in the fall or sometime seasonally or
get a a a a permit for um the whole
season to be able to burn it it is the
same thing I think it's $2 uh they
charge for a seasonal um burn permit so
questions that
it um I noticed that you in your new
Amendment you took out the first um
exception
that um originally you had there could
be an exception to this if the manner of
a flight intentionally interferes with
the reasonable use and enjoyment of the
park by other Park users which for
me I think the primary purpose of the
park is for people to enjoy the natural
world and I don't I I can see that
drones are in interference with that
and so why did you take it
out I mean I like the wording of that as
well but again this was going back to
Trisha Lambert's point about having
Federal overlap she actually wanted that
to be removed because she doesn't want
to have um any inkling that we're trying
to supersede federal law and we're only
dealing with takeoff and Landing but I
sentiment and actually I mean the
enjoyment is
putting putting restrictions on it
number one um could limit it to certain
months maybe that people aren't using it
or as much and and or you know certain
Parks you start with that um but again
it's someone who's as a hobbyist is
going to the parks they're using it in
the same way um to for
enjoyment to to be able to go and so um
the the parks everybody can have
have
I'm if we're all done I mean we just
take this uh information that we have uh
could you uh mail me copy of this
amendment I sent it to the whole
committee okay when
but I do do you want me to make the
Amendments um from what some of the
things we discuss here today or any any
amendment that you're going to submit or
even if uh or if you're looking because
that we're going to eventually get the
point and uh of uh executing this
so you'll there will have to so there
may be an amendment will be taken up but
I think I would like to be able to get
any any Amendment that's going to be
presented also sends it to Mr
Wilson
uh yeah send it to whoever send it to
whoever is as as interest in this okay
surprises thank you Mr chair I just for
the AK the presenter we have a meeting
um I believe it's next week Mr chairman
a spa committee um so if you have an
amendment to this if you can get it into
the chair and we can get it to the
committee at least in advance maybe the
the parks committee can talk about it uh
during next week's meeting we can try to
get it on the agenda it might be too
late but if you wait too late I can't
send it
in
um yeah the chair and me both go to
we're both going to the committee
meeting the Parks Commission special
parks
and it's called Spa SP yeah it's it's
the park commission and I think it's on
the agenda Mr chair when I got the
agenda for the meeting so they may
already discuss it but I'd like to get
them and amend it to this and some of
the changes that were suggested by
representative Darby I agree with the
about the the use on that line 17 and
some other parts thank
you very
good yes uh Trisha Lambert's behind me I
don't know if you guys have any
questions about how drones are divined
in Statue but she'd be able to answer
that if she wants to speak on anything
know
here
was that who who would ask the question
representative Darby well I mean I um so
you I believe you were the one at least
according to my notes and representative
Run's notes that brought up the
insurance and brought up RSA 422 for the
definition of UA U's so you know I guess
I'd like to see if you still uh agree
language so so just I um yes I I'll
address that I just want to be clear
like we're just here to deal with the
airspace um as far as landing and
takeoff it's completely up to the parks
so just for the for the record and again
I'm Trisha Lambert with the Bureau of
Aeronautics for the um with the
Department of Transportation and this is
Jason levit who uh is the uas planner um
in our Bureau so there is in statute
under 422 um um definitions for unmanned
aircrafts systems and small small s so
we would definitely prefer that be used
I think the FAA is already starting to
to morph into um uncrewed um so that
would probably need to be addressed but
the I don't I do not believe that there
is a definition for drone so yes that
would need to
be um changed in my opinion um to just
align it with those
definitions was there a second part to
your
question um my my notes had said
originally that sorry while I just
looked this up um that you know you were
one of the uh initial concerns you had
was that there was no requirement for
insurance and um can you speak to
that um so I'm not sure if I remember it
that way um uh maybe there was some
confusion but currently as it sits for
for for aircraft there is no requirement
for insurance
so I'm not quite sure what I said at the
time I'd have to go look at it but I
don't see that there would be insurance
for this because it is an aircraft based
upon the definition both for RSA and
with the federal government so therefore
I don't you know it's certainly up to
the legislature but they had repealed um
they had repealed insurance for all
aircraft so I would think that that
would be so now you'd have it for drones
but not for a man aircraft so that would
be up to the legislature but currently
it sits right now there is no
um Insurance
requirement apologize if I had said
something incorrect or it was some
confusion no that's great thanks one
other um minor thing that you had said
was um emergency landage should be
permitted without risk of fines you know
the $25 or
something um we would not want to
penalize anybody who was who was trying
to operate as the pilot in command of
that aircraft to land it in a safe
manner um and to add a penalty I would
feel that that would
[Music]
be they would try to make a different
decision when the safest decision may
have been to land it in that spot which
would be in the State Park or wherever
that would be so we actually um I do not
have a copy of that Amendment but um we
would we would want to see something
where that would be Exempted out um
thanks
is that
it
okay I'm just trying to clarify in my
head we already have Federal drone laws
in New Hampshire um to fly as a
commercial pilot as a hobbyist um if it
weighs more than a certain amount you
have to get a $5 permit um can we just
take that those laws and just those
rules and just apply it to take off and
landing in the Parks instead of
recreating and instead of Reinventing
the
wheel
so I'm just asking I don't I feel like
we're we're talking about so many
different things like do we have
insurance that the Federal don't require
any of that um they have to be within
your site you can't be that far away
from you
um there there are already so many rules
can we just take those rules and just
apply them to take off and landing in
our
Parks if I can answer I think I'll try
to answer that so two different things I
think the the premise of this bill in my
interpretation is simply to allow the
takeoff and
Landing the air space piece is already
in RSA 422 where if you would break
federal law you would break state law so
that already covers all those other
things in in my opinion um and that's
um it's in you know between the
definitions and the duties of for the
commissioner of the Department of
Transportation um that is where we put
it um in when we added the uas
definitions to cover make sure that was
covered so that was also added so I
think that covers most of it so it just
comes down to whether the state parks
would be per would it would be
permissible for them to allow landing
off okay all right I think we've got
all much as we can on this
and there's
any
there we've gotten this additional
information
so don't look on any additional meetings
until uh until the 1 where we
executive or does
somebody expect any or would like to do
any
discussion I think
we're there may
be I may if I hear if I hear from
folks schedule some kind of discussion
before the the executive
session uh if we if we
wish some kind of some kind of formal
hearing but if
not we will be just going
in uh into the
executive session with the data we
have all right with that thank you uh
for the testimony and 434 now going now
to
this is
the relative to the replacement of
temporary docks
representative rung you have an
amendment yes um you should have at your
2023-24
H um while you're looking at that I'll
just give you some background about the
work that's been done on this um over
the summer representative Darby and I um
talk to different stakeholders about it
um the prime sponsor representative
Crawford and I met with Harry vogle at
the lon
conservation uh commission or committee
and um we discussed it he rais some
concerns with having um a set amount of
feed he said sometimes Lon nests can be
endangered we don't have oh you don't
copies
it where did it did they stop what's
one know they stop
here oh whoops ah here they are never
got past
me never got past me stop I got we got
it never got past
me ah hey you know that's what happens
when you're walking and try to chew gum
at the same time thank you so what
you'll see with the amendment is we were
going round and round with the original
bill but there's already a statute in
place that gives the commissioner off
Fish and Game the
power um and you'll see it's um it's uh
um it's in uh RSA 212 a colon 2 but if
you look on the amendment line number 10
this is already in statute it says the
executive director May adopt and enforce
rules temporarily restricting boat
traffic on any Waters of the state as
the executive director deems necessary
to protect any threatened or endangered
species of wildlife in the earliest
stages of life so we already do that for
boats so it would meet the intent of the
bill just to also include with boats
temporary docks or
Inflatables so if someone's putting
something in the water whether it be a
boat dock or inflatable and it's
threatening the nesting site of an
endangered
species the fish and game um executive
director does have the power to go in
there and restrict it maybe it's a week
maybe it's two weeks whether it's a
month I don't know how long that nesting
period would be so instead of creating a
new statute we just the amendment is
just to add temporary docks and
Inflatables to what's already there um I
met with um Harry vogle yesterday I had
a phone call with him he's the the
director of The Loon preservation
committee he's happy with this um he
said there's only maybe one or two calls
they get a year that um we're someone is
calling because a loon Nest is
threatened so it's not like it's not
adding work to fish and game um and
those one or two calls actually are
really important because if a loon loses
its nest um because of an inflatable or
a temporary dock or a boat it won't
return and um because of their
endangered status we have to do whatever
we can to protect the the continuation
of those
nests
so um I'm happy to answer any questions
um representative Darby worked really
hard on this too all summer so I presume
representative Darby should have been on
here other than repres well I don't know
how your name got on there Mr chair but
you should be proud that that our names
are together but I don't know how it got
I think our names are next to each other
me
anyway any questions or comments anyway
what do you think is does it does it do
the
job I fully support this amendment as
it's written um and I really appreciate
the time and attention that's been taken
to make sure that this comes out to
everyone's liking I think it's a good
sign that your name is on the
amendment yeah I didn't scare anybody
off did
I not so far not so far well
representative Derby and I just like to
point out I think representative rung
mentioned this but this does address the
the large concern of the original um
bill that it was overly Broad in terms
of um you know endangered uh species and
that um that would have been it would
have been hard to enforce and there was
no way to actually um for those
temporary dock um people seeking temp
temporary dock permits to even determine
if they were within that restricted area
so this really puts the burden on
ultimately the the people that want to
protect the loons and there and thereby
an uh informing fishing game and and um
changes the the whole Dynamics to make
this much more much more straightforward
to um to enforce I
think
anyone anyone else have any any comments
the only comment I might have on that
just just that is that so long as
that it doesn't uh
that the commissioner is because there's
one it it it seems to
say he has the right
to uh enforce restricted boat traffic or
the use of the docks any
Waters it's really we're only talking a
small section of water and I don't want
any
confusion then that means that
oh one there's one one dock that's got a
loon problem we're going to shut we're
going to take all docks off of that Lake
that I don't want to give that kind of
authority but if it's if it's
even it's even anything to worry about I
don't think it is Mr chair because um
that language was boat so it originally
read temporary restricting boat traffic
on any Waters of the state so it's
really on any lakes or Rivers so it
doesn't mean like the whole lake or the
whole river it's just you know so if
there's a temporary seasonal dock on a
river that's interfering with an
endangered nesting site it it's so it's
not just exclusive intent there just
sometimes you know I don't want to give
this people can read it read it the way
they want them times you a I could I
could shut this whole thing down uh
representative Dar I I I can understand
the perspective I think that because
this uh this language uh allows the um
commissioner to adopt rules and they
already have adopted rules we can look
at how they've um how they've uh
interpreted it and and I think we can
assume that they would interpret it
good
anyone
else are we okay I will by the way I'm
going to send this I'll send a copy of
this to Darlene forc who does the uh uh
docs and make certain that she uh bues
into
it she's she's important as far as this
this
issue but down
that we all set I think we're all set oh
wait one one thing on uh on the on the
meeting we're going to have on uh
three
398 Pete we I
need
what is well you have a concern on what
we just had yes all right
up
thank you very much I'm Dan burger and
I'm the chief of the wildlife division
for the New Hampshire Fish and Game
department um we we did have an
opportunity to see um the proposed
language for this amendment and we we do
have some concerns about that um I'm not
aware that we have ever adopted rules to
restrict the boat traffic um in this
section um we have some concerns about
certainly the broadness of what um the
anchored seasonal platforms are um which
which if you look at the definition
could be anything the way I read it is
to even a a moing ball in a lake um we
um I'm not sure how exactly we would
enforce this um we do so RSA 2112a which
is our Endangered Species Act um already
does allow us to um it it prevents the
take of any threatened or endangered
species um so that alone I think may be
enough here um so if someone were to put
in a you know anything really or any any
practice that they might do whether it
be a seasonal dock um you know if if any
of those result in the take of an
threatened or endangered species then we
can we can step in there and there's
some enforcement ability already
um because of the broadness of this
amendment um I'm not exactly sure how I
I suppose it would be if someone um if
someone if something resulted in a take
we would be informed of that in which
case RSL RSA 2 2112a already already
gives us that ability without this
additional
language
okay representative
R um if if you're concerned about the
addition of temporary seasonal docks and
anchored seasonal
platforms um what what are you doing now
because it's already in statute about
restricting boat traffic when they're
threatening um endangered species
nesting grounds um it doesn't say
anything about taking it's just it only
talking about
specifically um their nesting locations
in their earliest stages of Life yeah I
I'm not I'm not sure as though there's
ever been a scenario where we've where
we've done that and I don't believe we
have any rules in place specific to the
boat
traffic okay so but we have the RSA in
place just rul support but there's no
there's no rules to support that okay
y then
Darby this is a bit strange to me
because I've been on uh Lake winnisquam
before up in the very Northern section
and there's a and I've canoed on that
and there's clearly markers that look
like they are um you know the same types
of markers that you'd see in no wake
zones or something like that that says
uh no access no boat access Lun nesting
area
so I so somehow those those markers got
put there yeah I my assumption would be
that those are probably um safety areas
LPC The Loon preservation um committee
under what uh under what
Authority I'm not sure I I'm not aware
that our department puts those signs up
it it's LPC them up it is LPC that puts
them up the Loon preservation committee
are they authorized by
Statute not that I'm aware of I think we
would be talking about that at this
point it sounds like a it sounds like a
uh maybe a private public partnership is
going on in this area um but uh I wonder
if it's appropriate
to um let me ask you would it be
appropriate for us to add a line that
invited your your um folks to develop
rules around this
this in in this amendment or in this
amendment yeah like if we added I'm just
saying if the if the sort of will of the
committee and the will of the
legislature were to do enforcement
preventative enforcement as opposed to
just post killing takings like if we
wanted to do preventative enforcement um
could we encourage rulemaking by by
including in this piece um not just the
temporary seasonal Docks but also
um uh the department shall make rules to
allow for the preventative protection of
um well I it's difficult to say I think
without speaking to our non-game people
on that specifically
the um
you know currently and I think you'd
referen that LPC referenced that they
might get one or two calls a year on
these um so I'm not sure that that that
legislation would even be necessary um
given what's already in Statute in
212a
um sure um okay thank you that's helpful
um there's
no in your work in your division is
there there's no problem with the LPC
protecting these no we work very closely
with them no absolutely we work very
else well is it possible that the LPC
can only put up those protective
barriers with permission from the Lake
Association that's why this legislation
might help uh if they can't get
permission yeah I I I I can't speak to
that because I'm not sure specifically
the scenarios when those are put up um
we had when the when the bill was
originally introduced we had proposed
some um some amendments you know our
concern initially was um with the
initial language of the bill pardon me I
me find
it um was that it had referenced impacts
to any Wildlife which which was very
broad we had proposed some legis um some
changes to the wording um that would
have you know focused it on unthreatened
and endangered species and put it in
line with some of the other existing
language um in our endangered species um
statutes the
um again I I I guess we we're not clear
how this would operate
um um we're not a permitting agency Dees
is a permitting agency so when we go
through that process like with the
existing wording in in in the bill um
wanted to issue the permit um so you
know with the original wording uh there
might be something like you know uh like
an nhb check that would I that would
help someone know that they were in some
sort of proximity to a Lon nest for
example um or or any feature that was
associated with threatened or endangered
species but um um the the proposed
amendment seems seems somewhat broad um
and we're not I'm not quite sure how how
that would work um unless it was you
know um already after the result of a
take regardless and again in which case
there's wording in RSA 2112a that that
allows us to address that
already um but I I think the whole point
of this bill was not to let it get to
the point where there's a take that um
we really want to prevent the loss of
the nest yeah I and I I agree with that
I'm not sure I'm not sure how this
proposed amendment would do that though
um unless there was some mechanism for
us to be aware that something was going
to happen prior to it happening which
which in my mind would would require um
some sort of system for people to
contact us to let us know and we'd have
to set up a whole new permitting system
which which quite frankly we're not
really um we don't have the the funding
or the Staffing to to set that up at
this
time um note that this um this amendment
completely you know differs from the
original bill which was involving
permitting this is no longer involving
permitting at all there's no there's no
permanent yeah I get that right and one
of the problems honestly with the
original bill was that it was only when
the original um permit was applied would
it um would it have come into uh effect
and oftentimes you know Nest loons are
made after the fact for example on a
lake that I'm on on Lake monomac um we
have a little island Sailing Club uh
Sailing Association owns it and the
loons decided luckily to take up a nest
on it and actually had a successful
hatch this year we're very happy but
that's a perfect example because they
actually had um a dock on that now
because it's a Sailing Association the
Len preservation committee talked to the
saling Association and said please don't
use your Dock and they were more than
happy to oblige but that's not always
the case um and so um the um to your
question about how it would how they
would be notified the lon preservation
committee knows because they have
monitors across the state where the um
uh where these loon nests are before as
they're building the nests before the
before the um eggs are laid um and
before this disturbance can can occur so
there's there's a clear very clear point
in time when it can uh when um the um
when the notification can take place and
then um I would claim that it's um up
because fishing game is responsible for
um non-game and protecting species like
loons um it would be up to them to work
with most likely uh Department of Safety
or something to to actually um to do
that enforcement um I I'm really
interested though on the broadness
though the terms that are used in this
um in this uh uh Amendment are exactly
taken from existing statute where there
are not only um uh you know definitions
and statute about it but also um rules
drafted by department of safety for so
the terms are actually very clear so I
I'm I'm concerned about the use of
broadness because this is not a broad
bill at all it's very narrowly scoped no
and I guess I'm thinking more of a
scenario where where the temporary dock
was you know not an existing structure
that's already there um I'm I'm thinking
more along the lines of a you know
because the original part of this bill
was the temporary seasonal docks so if
if one of those was going to be put out
um or constructed
um you know how that would How would how
would we know about that prior to an
individual doing it um and again LPC
does monitor these but but I could
certainly see scenarios um for example
the I think the situation where where
this bill came from was obviously a
missed thank you Mr chair I'm a little
confused
about what this this is about protecting
Nest the fishing game already May adopt
and enforce rules okay so that the rules
are already in the statute that would
temporarily restrict boat traffic so if
there if the LPC discovers oh there's a
there's a camp that's putting in all
these big
Inflatables um but they know it's it's
near a new loon nest and let's say the
operator didn't you know wasn't going to
restrict
activity the the LPC would then put up
those kind of those buoys that they have
to limit boat traffic just say but
they'd have to do that in conjunction
with fish and game because that's
already that that's being done now for
boat traffic you said you work in
partnership with LPC to have them
protect these Nest while during that
nesting cycle so what would be the
difference if we're providing that same
protection when there are these very
specific temporary structures placed in
water wouldn't we want LPC to be able to
restrict activity around there until the
nesting cycle is
over um yes um again I think part of our
concern was was particularly the
um um and I guess maybe it boils down to
the specifics of the rules that are
written in in conjunction with this but
um again those uh I think it was the
temporary seasonal platforms which which
again could even be just a moing ball um
um I suppose we would certainly be happy
to um to have further discussion and and
uh um um perhaps there's um perhaps some
some further discussion would um and
maybe the potential for what rules might
look like would would make us feel a
little more comfortable with it yeah
because we do have words and there the
the important word is as the executive
director of fishing game deems necessary
so it's not going to just be
any uh temporary dock even near a
nesting would have to be necessary to
protect that Nest um what Mr vogle was
explaining to representative Crawford
and me is sometimes you can have a
temporary dock within 50 feet of a
nesting of a nest and it's not going to
disturb the nest sometimes it could be
300 feet away so it's important to
understand what's what's deemed
necessary so I
think the wording that was used in the
original statute and then this amendment
is just adding those two items is is
really leaving it up to the
professionalism of fishing game to
determine if if a nest is at risk or not
and then giving fishing game the
authority to provide um to temporarily
restrict um so i' I'd be you know and it
does talk about rules and enforcement so
I I I think this is just all about
protecting that nest and allowing
fishing game to take that necessary
steps to protect that Nest during that
nesting cycle and I think we get away
from all of the issues that an an owner
would have with a do temporary dog
permit I mean there there was so many
holes in the original bill that we
discovered upon public hearing and I
think this really gets to the Crux of
what that legislative intent is um and
provides a great balance for fishing
game to construct those rules to
specifically protect nests of endangered
species in
water
so I I just wanted to clarify that okay
yeah
all right the uh 472 we're
uh that's it on that we'll uh I think
we're in good shape on
that uh the uh one one additional thing
on
398 uh haven't
actually formally uh determined the
people who the will be on three 398
right now I I've already talked to
representative uh mchu and Vale I've not
talked to representative Darby I would
like you to be on it because you wrote a
lot of did a bunch of the heavy lifting
on the
305 yeah 30 205
305 you know what's what's 100
yeah uh I would like you to be H it as
well
representative Healey the you've got
experience uh in sales and you you be
perfect for that uh those are I only
those are the four the voting members if
there's an others who want to be on that
committee uh uh on that
subcommittee speak up I can if you're
Republican and then I'll see if we can
find another Democrat we can we'll make
it six but uh I definitely needed the
the the that four the number of
four is there anyone else who want who
would wish to be on
it don't all jump on it that's uh Mr
chair yes um who are the voting members
for
194 that's the sub committee that's
meeting at one rung Ryan Vale me Healey
Harvey Barby
bu so but like I say everybody I will be
at94 I will be at the because I got to
be and I'll be at 398 but I'll just be
there to observe and put my two cents in
so everybody any like I say same rule
same
rules only thing is you can't vote on it
but uh but you can put your two cents
in and you can vote you definitely can
vote on it in the executive session I'd
like to if to get the executive session
in on uh on the 1 of
November uh 17th is the drop dead date I
definitely don't want to don't want to
be got close to the line uh so but
uh anything else can think of we all to
discuss if not no I think we've covered
everything um thank you Mr
chair anybody else any comments any
questions y yeah
wow got through
you
for